The answer is this equation right here, which goes with this triangle, a squared
plus b squared equals c squared. These other two right triangles are a special
kinds of right triangles and the equations right here that show the proporions
between their side lengths are particular to them individually and they don't
apply to all right triangles. But, now we do have a super important piece of
information that we can use, not just to talk about these three right triangles,
but also the one in Grant's situation and any other ones moving forward. This
equation, a squared plus b squared equals c squared, relating the side lengths
of any right triangle together is called the Pythagorean theorem. Julie
mentioned this way back in the very first lesson of this course. So, no big deal
if you didn't remember it or its name. We'll keep using it in the future,
though.